hi my name is matt and you're watching
code tech tutorials i have been studying
technology and involved in technology
for
quite a large portion of my life and
i've always analyzed
artificial intelligence very harshly and
critically and i want to answer a few
questions and talk about a few things
and go over
some of my thoughts feelings and some of
the current documentation and evidence
about
artificial intelligence intelligence and
the few main questions i want to answer
and talk about in sort of like a podcast
like format
is well will ai take over humanity
that's that's the one big thing we want
to address
part two we also want to look at will
artificial intelligence do everything
for us
which is of course different than taking
over humanity taking over humanity as
like will no longer have a say do
everything for us
is more like our lives are just going to
get really really
easy maybe too easy and the next part
will be
well ai make some people that know how
to use it correctly
too powerful so well let's dig in
now if you look at how most robots are
right now
they can sometimes do a little simple
things they're programmed to do
and there are some that are like being
programmed to talk and have a little bit
of a personality and things like that
but overall
most of these robots are overpriced and
rather useless make sure you can show
off to your friend for one second like
here
check this out my robot has an arm that
can grab something and then you're like
all right well there's like 10 seconds
of my day gone
and nothing really to show for it
because beyond the use of like
sorting things in a factory or something
or
turning a donut or whatever robots do
in factories there's relatively no use
for these little
very technical and goofy movements
in this video here which you can see
from cbc news
talks about how robots are starting to
take positions in factories
and this somewhat makes sense in
factories
they're often doing the same thing over
and over
and it is a very straightforward pattern
so
when you're writing a program to deal
with a pattern that's somewhat
considered a i but in my opinion that's
not ai that's just
it's just like a for loop going through
the same thing every time
with a few maybe if else statements to
detect
some cases but only cases specifically
programmed as you can see these robots
work and they're calling them
i don't know they're not really calling
them ai here they're just pre-programmed
to do
exactly what they're doing sure you
could have a human standing there doing
it or you could just have a robot do
obviously you make the robot do it
because no human wants to sit there and
do this all day
for a tiny bit of pay now this sort of
does bring up the issue
of more people need jobs and that sort
of thing is it really
cutting people out of their job i don't
know i guess that's up to
debate but i don't know how to really
get into that too much further
other than to say most of the jobs that
these robots are doing
i don't know anyone who would want to do
this more than a few times like
this stuff is just very very boring and
sure it'd be nice to do a few times just
see how it's done but after a while it's
like all right i'm just doing the same
thing all day every day is this really
my life i think most people like to move
on beyond that at some point so i don't
think robots and factories
are a big deal they're definitely a good
thing they're not really ai
you can't have ai run a factory right
now it's just not possible and if you
google robots working in factories you
get a whole bunch of different hits on
different things
most of them are rather short and most
of them are rather inconclusive like
yeah
robots and humans together are working
together in factories how else do we
mass produce all this stuff
not every single thing can be handmade
well
i guess it's a contradictory statement
it could but it won't be because it
doesn't really
make sense and we'll get into some of
that a little later now another big
phenomenon that's been kind of sweeping
the
the code and tech nation recently is
this idea
that machines can learn to code and
program themselves
and this is not exactly a new idea but
we don't see
a whole lot of realistic successful
cases here we see some small demo cases
where it's fed some really basic default
thing
and through apparently uh machine
learning which we'll talk about some
but i have my own thing on machine
learning i'm not sure how much i'll get
to that
in this video but i think this is a
rather
inconclusive thing because these are
really subject to
a lot of bugs and extremely hard to get
up and running properly and you have to
feed them
extremely specific scenarios for them to
be able to react correctly and that's
something we'll see over and over
with ai and machine learning and it's
it's
problems and the reason why ultimately i
don't think
it's going to take over humanity but
let's keep looking because there are
some more things
so robots can maybe replace humans
and and factories and producing stuff
which we see that's not really
very possible yet even with us
programming they can assist but they
can't really fully replace they still
need people to maintain them
and we see that uh with software writing
itself so if they could write themselves
and kind of make their own factory
you know hypothetically in the long run
or in 100 years
then that's a huge step but is something
like that ever
really going to happen or be possible
now to say even if it is possible
on some level ai comes to a roadblock
when it needs
resources sure it can program itself now
hypothetically we'll say that
it can't even though that's not
something that's
viable but what if it could and what if
they could actually run factories and
produce stuff and build stuff where they
get the resources
they still need humans to go figure out
that where do they gather wood how do
they gather coal
all the other materials and elements and
metals whatever they may need to produce
whatever they're trying to produce
that's a big roadblock so they would
need to make some kind of machine
to go harvest resources that resource
gatherer would have to bring back
resources
so they could actually do what they want
to do and it's just a whole
very convoluted difficult loop that an
ai cannot just solve
easily and so i did some searching on
this and
there is some research into this some
new
research it looks like there are some
robots that do agricultural
farming to some extent and i've seen
some of these
just like little machines that go by and
water and maybe trim a little bit
and those are kind of cool but that's
not true that's like harvesting food
what about
metal and stuff like that and the the
elements you need to make electronics in
other robots
that's a whole other thing and i
couldn't find much on that but let's
have a gander oh this one is all about
agricultural which sure i see that
happening i see robots coming into
agricultural
after all fruits are often a very
distinct color when they're ready and
things like that
and often very distinct shapes so that
might be something ai could do but that
doesn't really help ai
advance itself which is what we're
looking at if ai is going to take over
humanity this is
more of an assistant and it's hard to
call
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence sometimes as weird as that
sounds because often it's just running
an
algorithm it's looking for a shape and
you can you know you're going through a
loop looking for the shape
and that's just an algorithm i don't
know if you can call that intelligence i
guess it's artificial intelligence
meaning the word all right i'm eating my
own words here but hopefully you get the
point here
on ai being more of an assistant and
running through a predefined algorithm
i feel like that's a lot different than
actual intelligence
is it artificial intelligence then it is
very artificial but i feel like it's
more like why would you call it
artificial intelligence it sounds more
like
an algorithm so i guess that begs
another question that i don't think i'm
going to get to
any further i sort of accidentally
brought it up is
ai just an algorithm or is an actual
artificial intelligence and what's the
difference
leave a comment below because that's as
far as i'm going to dive into that topic
and just digging through some google
resources here it looks like almost all
of this is all
about farming food nothing about
anything else but let's refine the
search alone let's change it to
harvesting
materials here's one about clean energy
and harvesting light
that just solar power and more about
agriculture so
yeah we don't see really any cases of
machines being able to
go out and mine [ __ ] or anything like
that
so in any case even if they could write
their own software to build their own
robots they don't seem to be able to get
their own resources
thus they would still need a human
involved so that sort of means that
ai's gonna have a lot of trouble taking
over humanity if it can't sustain itself
more than one generation or one battery
life but
will ai ever wage war or be used in
combat well i think it already is and
there are some
articles this one being two years old
that talk about automated forms of
warfare
and how you know war is going to be much
more deadly and ai does play
a uh part in that as we'll have things
like cameras that can detect
human shapes and maybe ask for something
and if you don't show a certain badge or
something maybe they'll become hostile
and things like that but those are still
pretty algorithmic based like if you
have to show a badge that's going to go
off the shape of the badge
and a lot of this stuff could be faked
and we will get to that later about
faking
ai and making it malfunction because if
that is extremely easy to do and one of
the big drawbacks but more on that in a
later part right now we're going to talk
about
can ai potentially wage war will wars in
the future
start based on what an artificial
intelligence thinks
and what another one thinks and maybe
they'll have opposing ideas
and things like that i know sounds
far-fetched
but let's dig in a little bit one famous
example people like to bring up
about artificial intelligence as the old
terminator movies
where james cameron somewhat gives his
take on
what the future could look like if ai
took over and became a warlike machine
and in here we see some pretty
interesting things like
the idea that machines will time travel
which of course we know is fully
impossible
i'm not going to get into the details of
that but basically we know the time
travel is impossible although
warping time is a whole different story
as far as we can tell
and that can be summarized is the faster
you're moving time is different for you
while it feels the same
you will age differently than the people
moving at different speeds
so it's all to think about dig into it
if you want but of course in this movie
this guy's an
ai a robot and so is the main terminator
are
sorts but you know there's basically a
big war coming it's i don't want to go
into the plot of the movie but i feel
like
there's something to show here and i
don't know what it is honestly because
this movie is is in a way
where robots would have to learn to
harvest for themselves
replicate themselves write their own
software to ever get to this and then be
able to time travel so this movie is
obviously too far-fetched but
it still serves as an example of what
the world could turn
into if a.i did wage war but honestly i
just don't think it's possible
ever other than in weird situations like
i don't know maybe some terrible and
derpy leader would listen to some ai's
analysis of something and then decide
they need to wage war
or something like that but in any real
case it's not going to do it
all on its own so i think i'll leave it
at that as far as
ai waging war but just what if it could
wage war
and it did and just all on its own
without any human interaction decided
all right it's time to take out whatever
it may want to take out or decide
needs to take out could it execute war
tactics
i suppose that's more viable than a lot
of other things assuming that it could
write and replicate itself and make
appropriate machines and harvest
resources then sure
it could he could probably execute some
tactics but otherwise it couldn't
now people like to say okay we we sent a
drone out somewhere to go do something
it was unmanned it just did its thing
okay well someone programmed it to do
what it did
so while it was unmanned there was still
a man behind it
it didn't just make itself and go do
whatever it needed to do
so in general right now even when people
say oh we used an ai to go do that uh
you i think it's more like you used an
algorithm to go do it because ai isn't
isn't very viable or reliable yet and
we'll get into that more later
too all right that's enough of this
section let's move on to the next
[Music]
section
okay this one's a little tricky because
it's sort of already true
will artificial intelligence do
everything for us
well there'll be a time where we pretty
much don't need to do
anything during our day other than what
we want to do and
things are just handled for us all the
things we need and should be doing let's
take a look
well the first thing big thing is how do
we get around
how do us humans travel and get to where
we need to go
and of course artificial intelligence is
deeply embedded in this as a lot of big
technology companies i don't think i
even need to name them you'll see them
all over the place
trying to figure out how to get cars to
drive on their own
without any human involved just give it
a location it goes there
and you see lots of videos on the
subject you see lots of studies on the
subject
and i'm not buying it i wish it were a
thing
right now it seems like most navigation
stuff can sort of detect the edges of
roads
in the center of roads and other cars
and some objects
and stuff like that but beyond that they
don't seem too
great and as soon as there are no edge
lines on the road then they just don't
function anymore and things like that
and also just one little small error or
slip-up could have you
careening into another car or into a
barrier who knows what
sure that's unlikely with how currently
advanced it is usually they just stop
and pull over
and say and ask for a human to take over
which
kind of defeats the purpose if you ask
me so
ai for for maps and navigation and
driving is part of doing everything for
us
while it sort of helps right now it's
often quite a hindrance
i can definitely say there there have
been at least two instances in my life
where i'm pretty sure
maps and navigation from gps's have
actively
attempted to uh off me like permanently
like once one tried to get me to drive
off a cliff i kid you not it was like
turn right off this cliff and i was like
no
i'll choose to live today thanks gps so
um it's happened to me i don't know how
many other people it's happened to
also had an instance where it for some
reason i was on like a main highway
going a long distance
and just kind of listening to my gps
like okay take this route and at one
point it just decided it was going to
take me out
some back road that was a dead end in
like this
area that looked really sketch so it
gets there takes me to a dead end and
then when i get to this dead end it says
return to road it's like you took me
here what do you mean
so i don't i'm pretty sure that uh this
whole maps and navigation thing is far
far far off we would actually i think
for it to actually be
like 100 reliable we'd have to have a
grid
system laid out and that's just not
going to happen
at least not in a giant scale across the
world because
you know our world changes the tectonic
plates shift
things move around you could make
temporary ones or small
area ones but generally traveling across
the world and state and all these
conditions
ai is not going to do the forest anytime
soon although it will try
and it will have some serious blunders
and if we all just listen to it we'll
probably end up
cooked like i would be cooked if i had
listened to ai
my whole life because i would have drove
off a cliff now
some haters might like that i don't know
that's something funny to say i guess
most people here have been relatively
awesome so
i'm just going to take this quick moment
to shout out and say thanks to my
viewers and all the people that do
watch me a lot of great people out there
love to see you just just a few
crazy eggs that have left some weird
comments maybe i'll put one up here
crazy comment number one all right
let's move on to the next part of this
voice recognition
so you want to be able to just talk to
your phone or device and have it do
things for you
now voice recognition you would think is
not too difficult to get right
except as you may have already noticed
in my speaking in this video
sometimes i blunder a word or i miss a
syllable or something like that
humans just aren't perfect so it's
really hard
to get a proper voice recognition and in
my
experience it's not very good i don't
know if it's improving or not but
for me personally i try to use text to
speech a lot from my phone because i
don't feel like typing out long-winded
things over text
sure a lot of people do this well
sometimes i'll look down
at what it wrote for me and it is
something just so
far off and wacky compared to what i was
saying it can't seem to pick up my slang
like when i say
what's up or something it translates
that into something weird i don't know
let me just do a test hold on a second
so maybe let's just give it a quick go
let's give it a quick test i've got my
phone here
and i'm gonna go to a little voice
recognition prompt
say a few things maybe something i would
text to someone so let me go ahead and
just bring that right up okay i'm trying
to find
give me a second i'm trying to find
something that someone i can text
without like confusing a lot here we go
try this okay so i'm gonna press my
voice recognition
prompt and start talking and now we're
gonna see what this translates
this to hey quick question when you're
done with work do you think you could
pick up some milk and eggs and maybe a
piece or two on the way home
okay and that translated to a quick
question when you're done with work do
you think you could pick up some milk
and eggs and maybe
a piece or two on the way home a piece
or two not a pizza but a piece
so imagine you're saying something
really important where the words you use
are critically important and it just
like
substitutes something in randomly i'm
sure you've seen some memes about this
where people got absolutely destroyed
sending i don't know
really inappropriate stuff to their
friends family mom dad et cetera and all
the times i've used this little text
thing
sometimes i think oh that's a really
simple thing to say it's not going to
get that wrong i would say 90
of the time this gets my voice
recognition wrong it almost
never gets it correct and it's really
actually quite frustrating because i
don't know about you but when i'm
driving or something
i don't i don't want to text i'd rather
not you know if i get stopped at a
stoplight with nothing to do for a
second i might
say okay or something but generally i
was picking my phone hit the button say
what i need to say and hit send
and just hope that it didn't send some
totally inappropriate thing
to whoever i'm talking to so you know
and that's google's latest this is
updated as of today with google software
voice recognition terrible barely
functional or it's better than nothing i
guess
but it's just the ability for it to
absolutely destroy
context and say words it the wrong word
all the time it blows my mind like that
one was a rather tame one it just turned
pizza into peace
could you pick up a piece on the way
home that doesn't even make any sense
piece of what
shouldn't be able to detect that that
doesn't make sense i don't know but it
can't now let's talk a little bit about
facial
recognition okay facial recognition is
tricky
a lot of new things are saying you know
you'll see on like the new
mac stuff that they have face
recognition you can flip open your
laptop and take a look at it and say hey
scan my face
and it'll just unlock for you and
apparently banks are starting to do this
too and i don't know what to think of
this um
on one hand sure it's kind of cool but
i've heard that people can get
replicas made of other people and just
hold it up in front of the camera
and there you go and they can do that by
acquiring images that you've publicly
posted on instagram facebook etc and get
some kind of mold made out of your face
and then use your face to unlock things
now i don't know how true this is
and i haven't heard of any real cases of
it or anything like that but if
something like that were
actually possible if you could just 3d
print someone's face get it all painted
up correctly and all the structures
right
and then unlock their devices with it
get into their bank account with it
that is a little concerning to me though
i wonder if there's more factors
to this let's have a little gander so i
did a google search for how easy is it
to
fake facial recognition or confuse it
and we do see some new articles
and some new videos uh looks like this
is a relatively new subject well i guess
we've seen them for a while we
3d printed our heads to bypass facial
recognition there's even a video from
forbes here and let's see if we can get
to the conclusion of this in this video
here from uh
forbes we see that this guy did a test
had his face 3d printed and he did
actually even with the strongest
settings unlock his phone with this fake
model of his head so this was 2018
maybe the facial recognition has gotten
a little stronger since then but
it looks like this is a pretty viable
strat for unlocking
these devices so yeah they did a bunch
of different phones
and yeah basically it was very possible
to just
unlock things with a 3d replica of your
head
so i don't think facial recognition is
very secure for that reason of course it
is
it is a giant set of difficulty weird
way to say that i know
to go and get someone's head printed and
maybe cost a lot of money or a little
money but if you have the means to do it
it's a pretty easy way in
to someone's account if you know they
use facial recognition so
i personally wouldn't ever use facial
recognition because of this reason and
the
problems of security hopefully that
improves
but uh yeah that's a bit concerning what
do you guys think another thing i wanted
to take a quick look at why we're
looking at uh whether ai can do
everything for us
is well can it entertain us currently it
takes a
writer producer actors and a whole suite
of individuals to make most entertaining
content or just a single individual in
the case of a lot of youtubers yeah
that's a that's a shout out to
do the buttons hit the buttons thanks
all right well let me
let me really dig into this for real can
ai make content can it make films can it
make demos can make youtube videos can
it make
a whole channel can it write books
uh general stuff like that and well the
short answer is yes it can
but in my experience these are typically
pretty bad
like there are definitely some ai
youtube channels where it's purely ai
generated content and some of them have
a decent amount of subscribers i'm not
going to show you any of those
now because i don't want to give them
free advertising they're already they're
already milking it with their easy free
content now that's not the true reason i
just don't feel like digging in but
it does happen they're pretty easy to
find sure someone will post something
eventually about them
down below there are a lot of them i've
seen
you know when i was in college i was in
an ai course
and one of our projects was to look at
something made by ai
and real world use and i looked at a
a trailer made for a movie it was a
movie about ai
and they made the trailer with a.i fed
it the whole movie they said okay well
they i was programmed to pick certain
parts that were most interesting and put
them together
and while it could get a nice like you
know one a minute and 30 seconds worth
of clips the thing it couldn't do
was write a story that made sense like
the order and the transitions were all
over the place
it was hard to follow so it did take the
uh
the handiwork of human to go in and
clean up the ai's work but the ai did
a good chunk of the work of picking out
the interesting scenes it just couldn't
put them together
in an order that was easy to follow and
made sense to follow though that's what
i found in
some study in college but you know that
is one thing they can do for us it just
seems like as of right now
ai can't make very interesting content
they make something that's like oh
that's cool because they i did it but if
it were like someone else doing it i
would rail them
in and give them a hard critique and a
down vote because it's so bad
it doesn't make any sense but since ai
made it then cool thumbs up you know
that's
that's like the current state of ai
making content and i think that kind of
ties in with can ai program itself and
stuff like that
it's just it's so bad at like figuring
out like logical
context that makes sense that it just
has a hard time
stuff like that but what else can it
potentially do for us
can it pay bills can it trade stocks
well it's not really ai that does this
sort of thing
you can call it ai but they're still
just algorithms sure you can you can
design an algorithm that looks at the
history of a stock tries to determine
whether to buy it or not and maybe you
can make something that executes
based on that decision whether to buy or
sell i wouldn't call that a
i i would call that an algorithm and
same for paying bills
sure you get billed every once a month
for something or once a year or
something like that
you can just have autopay turned on
that's
sure while it's being done for you you
still got to be careful that you know
you actually have money in your account
and stuff unless
i don't know think about this scenario
though what if you had ai
that automatically made content for you
and when you got paid
you used whatever you got paid for
making that content to auto pay your
bills so essentially you set up the
system of content creation
that somehow makes you money maybe
through youtube ads or something i don't
know
just hypothesizing here and then it
takes that money and whatever
account it goes into it pays your bills
with it so essentially once you set up
this content creation machine you know
you can have all your bills paid now
that's something that might actually
be viable but you still need to be
behind it you still need to
take it make sure it's actually making
good enough content for people to watch
and stuff like that so it's still going
to be
still going to be a lot of human element
to that sort of thing although it is
that that is kind of a cool
concept if think about it well i think
it's time
we jump on to the next subject
will ai and machine learning make some
people
too powerful let's dig in this is a
really really deep subject and i think
the answer is yes is ai getting too
powerful will ai go out of control
according to 52 experts worried about ai
taking over the world
now the biggest thing here is the use of
deep
fakes in my opinion and i mean let me
just pull up some so a youtuber named
glink who does a lot of technology and
game type videos
recently made a video about how ai is
taking a
it changed the world and you didn't
notice well i don't i don't think this
is a very good title because most people
did notice
i guess maybe some people didn't i don't
know it's decent click baity title he
knows more than i do
whatever but the point here is in what
he's going with this whole video that he
came out with just a few days ago
relatively new video
is all about how you can fake a face
on to an actor and do anything and
there's a lot of examples here this is a
cool video i highly recommend watching
i'm not going to you know
do the whole thing here but basically he
talks about how
people can deep fake talks like
they could get an actor to do something
put donald trump's face on it and say
hey the president said this or they
could do that with zuckerberg or any big
influencer it can be done this is
currently
a technology that works and that is
sometimes believable um i don't think
it's as believable as
it's made out to be anytime i look at
one of these deep fakes
if you just look closely you can always
tell that like the face doesn't
quite look right there's always
something a little off but if it's done
really well you can't really tell it's
just it's just hard to get it perfect
so these whole deep fakes while they're
neat and
it's a viable concern i think it's just
too easy to tell but once it gets to the
point where it's not too easy to tell
this could be a problem
because this is something that someone
someone that's not necessarily
involved in i don't know politics or
something they could just
for lack of a better way to say it they
could sit in their basement program up
this
elaborate deep fake of some thing
happening and get
a reaction out of a lot of people and
potentially start or cause a lot of
problems
based on the reactions they could cause
by these these fakes
and they say hey so so did this said
this and here's how so-and-so responded
we got to do something and turns out it
was all fake you know stuff like that so
that's the biggest concern like oh you
got to watch this video if you like this
topic because like
some of this stuff is funny like this
president they were saying this is a
deep fake his little talk because of the
way his eyes are and stuff
and i don't know i guess he also had a
stroke or something recently so
maybe not but people still don't know if
this is a deep fake or not so there's
there's some interesting things going on
with this deep fake and i think
personally this whole deep fake thing
can make people a little too powerful
it makes social hacking a little easier
in a lot of cases
and also another concern is people can
deep fake you
or anyone they can grab all your images
off your public social media
and superimpose you and make you do or
say anything stuff that you don't agree
with and
even for let me see there was one other
thing here somewhere that was
interesting and it was about some
kid who got shot in a school shooting
and his parents
here he is his parents made it basically
a deep fake
robot of him they hired an actor put
their son's face on him and it's
basically an
ad against school shootings and gun
control it's a hat against guns or
something like that
i'm butchering that but it was his
parents their his parents decision
this kid had no say in what i don't know
given
how he got unfortunately uh murdered i'm
sure he would be fine with it though i
mean why wouldn't he be
okay do you mind if we use you to help
stop prevent this in the future
of course he's going to say yes but i
don't know glenn kind of stated that he
didn't give consent
because you know he's not around anymore
but you know if he's under 18 and his
parents wanted to do it
i think that's fine so yeah well sure
trolls can use this or uh evil things or
malicious things there's also
some good use of this uh deep fake thing
and i guess there's another big thing
that i haven't really touched on
it's something i guess there was a black
mirror episode of this
i don't see it here but basically this
uh this girl's boyfriend gets killed in
one of these episodes
and uh she ends up getting like buying a
robot of him but it's
of course it's not actually him it's
just like you know takes all his public
accounts and stuff and and they
make personality and basically it's this
deep fake of a real person that really
exists
and a robot and you know it's a black
it's a black mirror episode so it was
pretty interesting one i think it was
like season two episode one i could be
wrong on that but anyway
the point of that is it was it was
highly unrealistic
it was like they took it to a level
where it's obviously not possible and
it's not going to be possible for a long
time in that show
but apparently you can still get like
some things you can have things said in
the voice of people like like that video
i was just talking about
this they had his voice and he's no
longer around just based on recordings
they were able to use ai to make his
voice and they were
able to use ai to replicate him like a
hologram kind of like that tupac one
they did a while ago
so i don't know if that's a viable thing
you know i guess it is it's sort of like
a memory thing or
remember this person but to have them
say stuff and do stuff from the grave
sort of weird i don't know pushing the
boundaries a little bit maybe
of what's uh morally correct in my
opinion but
you know if everyone consents that that
could in
uh you know like in this case anyway i
don't think this is too agree
grievous of a of a thing but there could
be cases where it's it's real bad like i
don't know
i'm sure you can think of something like
i don't know maybe using
hitler to try to reinstate something and
fake that he came back
like heaven's gate called stuff and say
hey hitler's back
let's restart this whole thing and
people will actually believe it because
of course they will have
just look at some of the stuff your
facebook friends are saying they they'll
believe anything
it's we're in a goofy world this ai is
dangerous
it does make people too powerful i do
believe that let's look at some more
examples all right well i just
searched elite ai programmers and i was
kind of
along the lines of thinking okay well to
be really powerful this stuff
you either need to be really good at
programming in ml and all that stuff
or you need to hire someone but someone
needs to be pretty good to be able to
program all these this stuff
up generally it takes a lot of work it's
not just necessarily automatic
someone's behind it it's the point i'm
trying to make here but where my concern
comes in is with spam calls
spam calls is a really unique subject
here because it's
very relevant very relevant to almost
all of us willing to bet you've got a
spam call today have i
pretty sure i've got a spam called i get
at least a few every day and i block
so many numbers well there's a problem
with just blocking these numbers
now i'm going to just google not google
search just youtube search
spoofing phone numbers how to on on
youtube and i know
that this works because i've seen people
do it i've seen tutorials on how to do
it and it's just something that
should be highly illegal in my opinion
did you know that your phone
number no longer matters what's your
phone number oh i don't want to tell you
what if i tell you it doesn't matter
anyone can just spoof your number
for free they can just call someone else
and say
that it's coming from you or from anyone
that's why you get all these numbers
from like local places and it
turns out it's like some kind of car
sales or some insurance sales or some
weird thing
they're spoofing these numbers they're
not even calling from that number and
you can do it with all this voip
technology you can set up stuff
set up asterisk caller ids spoofing
prevent caller id spoofing how to
scammers spoof calls how to protect
yourself there's ways to do it i've seen
a tutorial about how to set it up on a
raspberry pi and hook it up to a voip
system to do it yourself
it's actually relatively easy to do the
software is already out there you don't
need to program anything you just need
to turn on the software and start
putting in numbers basically
so yeah it's really easy to do anyone
can do it
this whole spam calls with spoofed
numbers
is really out of control something needs
to be done about that i don't know what
exactly but i'm pretty sure
that phones are you know these
traditional phones and phone numbers are
going to go away
real quick and a lot of companies are
going to go downhill very quick like
verizon and all these service providers
because no one's going to want a phone
number anymore if it can be spoofed
and if you just get spam called by spoof
numbers all day like
it's a i don't know what to do about
that it's it's not up to me but i kind
of i already feel the urge to move on to
something else
like why not just use some encrypted
messenger account that generally
connects to the internet then no one can
spam you only your actual friends know
how to get in contact with you you're
not going to get a bunch of redundant
nonsense
on your phone all day just not to
mention one you pay a bill for
which makes it even more ridiculous when
you think about it because you can
there's all sorts of messenger accounts
and and account and
voice accounts you can make for free or
you won't get spammed all day
so yeah i think phones and the
traditional phone number
this whole spoofing thing doesn't get
corrected is going to be a thing of the
past and that's because
people just hold way too much power with
being able to just spoof like it's
nothing all you need is a raspberry pi
and a voip system which is not very
expensive like we're talking 100 bucks
or maybe a little more and you got
yourself a spam calling system ready to
go but can ai
make sales and i'm going to say yes how
many times you've been called by a
probably spoofed number
and they start talking to you about
buying insurance they're buying a
alarm system and ask for a yes or no and
it's a robot
no one is manning the system no one is
there they just turn on the thing
and it starts trying to make sales calls
your grandma calls
to everyone you know and eventually it
gets a hit here and there where someone
says okay yeah i need whatever that is i
need that alarm system sure you're
making it easy
so i think yeah aki has the ability to
make sales and we're diving into some
pretty interesting things
this is not really ai though this is
once again algorithms
i don't know the the divide between
algorithms and ai
what really makes the difference there
seems like people just call a
really good algorithm that messes with
people it's a really good algorithm that
messes with people it's now an ai that's
that seems to be the thing which i don't
know if i agree with that but yeah
it seems like people are too powerful
because of this stuff and it is
it is scary it's making it's giving
scammers a lot of power so
we've got to find ways to combat it i
guess
[Music]
will ai take over humanity no no chance
it can't harvest resources
it needs too much human interference and
interaction and programming it can't
program itself
not very well it's just it's just no
good itself replicating on a
physical level so i think because of
that it can't really take over humanity
will it do everything for us one day it
will probably do most of the stuff for
us or at least we'll be able to set it
up in a way where it can do most
stuff for us but it's still going to be
quite dangerous it's not something you
can just
blindly follow because it will literally
drive you off a cliff like it tried to
do to me once i'm not bitter or anything
i
wasn't it's it's fine that ai tried to
kill me once it's fine thanks google
um and will it make some people too
powerful and the flat out answer
to that is yes and it already is making
some people too powerful especially with
all these spoofing
and spam that's that's where it's the
worst it's not like it's making two
people too powerful because they have
auto turrets like you do in games or
anything
while sure that's becoming possible and
already is as we saw with the military
stuff
it's not something everyday humans can
can do easily
but it is but i say that now and as i
think about it i think
actually that's not that hard you just
set up a camera with some some human
recognition and then set up a thing that
points at it and you know
triggers it wouldn't be that hard but uh
that's
something that's apparently already used
by the military stuff like that but the
whole spam call and spoofing is where
people really get a lot of power and to
and to make sales that way too it just
makes it a viable business model so it
makes them want to keep doing it all
right
and now some of my personal thoughts
just to wrap this up i think artificial
intelligence and algorithms are
generally
for menial tasks you can't do really
complicated things with them
and while that's changing every day and
it's becoming better every day that fact
isn't going to change any time too soon
maybe in a hundred years
it'll be able to do more complicated
tests like people say oh you can you can
it can drive for you no it can't it can
sort of drive for you but a lot of times
it's going to pull over and be like
human needs to take over i can't handle
this
because i'm going to want to wreck and
blow up everything so ai's just not as
good as you think
it's overblown and all these commercials
and the hype about auto driving and
stuff
it's it's not as good as it seems but in
some cases it's it's
really good but only in some cases ai
tends to butcher things
and sometimes it butchers them very
badly as we saw with the whole voice to
text thing
sometimes it butchers things very badly
and it's while it's funny
if you're trying to use it for some
serious situation or something you need
to get right it's just not something you
can rely on
ai for you got to go do it yourself it's
like that old saying if you want
something done right you got to do it
yourself
and that's true even for ai ai is not
very good at doing it right
it might get it right it might but
there's just no guarantee right now oh
ai basically just messes up
a lot and it wrecks things it butchers
things it just uh it's it's a bit
frustrating when you rely on it to be
honest i i'd almost rather not every
time i try to rely on it it does
something
devastating that i'm just like no delete
go back
no oh yeah i think that's my conclusion
about ai
well it's gonna do it for this video let
me know what you guys got over
out of this and i hope you enjoyed
my analysis on the current state of ai
it's a very
broad and brief overview it's something
i've been thinking about for a long time
and i think i've covered most of the
stuff but if i've missed anything
glaring or anything really cool that you
think i should
address or do a part two on feel free to
let me know and i'll be answering
comments
for at least the next uh hopefully a
week i'll try to go week on this one
thanks again
all right peace out guys take care
yourselves out there don't rely on ai
too much and all your business matt from
codetech tutorials over and out peace
[Music]
[Music]
you